chris wallace fox news sunday anchor
dana perino host of the daily briefing
coast the five juan williams
also fox news political analyst co-host
of the five chris now we start to look
forward
right and this transition time is a time
when uh the biden camp will start
playing the parlor game of who's going
to be secretary
of defense who are going to who's going
to be filling out the cabinet
you're already hearing names like
michelle flournoy at the pentagon the
first
possible female defense secretary this
is where we will be
shortly even as these legal challenges
are going forward
absolutely we're told now that uh on
monday the first thing
that president-elect biden is going to
do is he's going to name a coronavirus
task force
uh and and to basically make the message
that more important than a chief of
staff more important
than some of those cabinet positions
that you're talking about
is we're going to take this coveted
crisis facing the country seriously uh
and we're going to deal with it and i
think you're going to see
them roll out some policy ideas some
personnel ideas
and make it clear you know regardless of
what the president does
they're moving full ahead in these in
these closing moments i just want to say
one thing uh the power of what we are
seeing
right now i mean you had ari fleischer
and mark thiessen
two rock rib republican uh
fighters and they began their
appearances here tonight today on fox
saying
congratulations to president-elect joe
biden here we have on fox the the
chiron at the bottom of the screen the
headline joe biden elected 46th
president
of the united states on fox uh you see
these
uh the crowds celebrating uh in the
streets of new york and
and other cities across the country uh
you know there's a tremendous momentum
you know we just called this race just
before noon it's just before
2 in the east now and there's a
tremendous momentum that is already
picking up that that joe biden is the
duly elected president of the united
states
uh the president trump may be
digging in his heels and he may have his
lawyers out but you know there was a
fictional bartender named mr dooley
around the turn of the century and he
famously said a quote
that lived long after the stories about
mr dooley
that said the supreme court follows the
election returns
and you got to think with all of this
momentum building up
and you know around the country
and in the news media that that
it's going to be awfully hard for any
judge or let alone a supreme court
justice
to put their foot in the door unless
there is
very strong evidence of industrial
strength
uh election fraud and we've seen none of
that so far
chris thank you